esta deja una estela de destrucción en
centroamérica las inundaciones y los
deslizamientos de tierra han provocado
decenas de muertes miles de evacuados y
daños materiales
en guatemala el gobierno informó al
menos 50 decesos como consecuencia de
los deslaves siendo izabal en el norte
del país la zona más afectada
en nicaragua el país al que está llegó
como una can de categoría 4 los fuertes
vientos y las lluvias han devastado
comunidades indígenas y poblados
alejados de la costa norte del país
sus habitantes se lanzan un pedido
desesperado de ayuda no tenemos nada
totalmente ayer cuando vine me sentí
pesado hasta me puse a llorar porque no
tengo nada el gobierno también ha venido
a visitarnos y nos ha preguntado cómo
estamos en honduras hay más de 6 mil
evacuados por las inundaciones que
sorprendieron a pobladores de zonas
rurales del norte del país ha sido muy
doloroso porque fue tanto
tan rápido la llenaba no hay menos que
lo creíamos ahí nos estábamos durmiendo
a las doce de la noche cuando empezó a
llenar aquí la tormenta también golpeó a
panamá con decenas de desaparecidos y
comunidades aisladas y a costa rica que
reportó más de 300 deslizamientos y más
de 1.300 evacuados mientras que el
salvador decretó la alerta máxima por
lluvias y puso a resguardo a más de 1000
personas